[Musica]
sono molto felice di parlarvi oggi di
intelligenza artificiale che di fatto è
un tema che studio utilizzo
sviluppo ed in segno da più di 30 anni e
che è una tecnologia che è diventata
pervasiva nella vita di tutti noi e ci
servirà per migliorare la vita di tutti
noi nel bene e nel male naturalmente in
questi minuti vi parlo del bene non del
male perché sono fermamente convinta
anche una tecnologia come questa come
tutte le tecnologie se utilizzati in
modo corretto
responsabile corretto per le nostre
leggi per la nostra etica possa davvero
fare bene alla nostra vita questo vale
per tutte le tecnologie me vale ancor di
più per l'intelligenza artificiale che
nasce dagli esseri umani e impara a
modellare la nostra conoscenza e la
nostra esperienza ed è quindi
estremamente vicina alla nostra vita ed
è proprio per questo che il titolo di
questo mio talk e è l'intelligenza non è
artificiale perché credo fermamente che
l'intelligenza artificiale non sia
artificiale ma sia il frutto dell'uomo
degli ingegneri che la progettano di è
di chi la modella e di chi ha la
responsabilità di insegnare attraverso i
dati attraverso l'ottimizzazione di
queste le migliorie aspetti che possono
essere portati in un mondo artificiale
d'altra parte la lei ai intelligenza
artificiale dove lo userò questo termine
non è soltanto ricerca come sono
abituato a fare all'interno
dell'università ma è pervasiva era
diventata una serie di prodotti e
probabilmente tutti noi lo sappiamo
abbiamo già migliaia di intelligenze
artificiali che vivono attorno a noi che
influenzano le nostre vite
vi faccio soltanto alcuni esempi per
farvi capire di che cosa sto parlando
pensate per esempio a tutto quello che
utilizzato giornalmente nei calcolatori
negli smartphone ovunque tutti le suite
di google per esempio di amazon di tutte
le altre grandi case costruttrici che
riconoscono il parlato e possiamo
parlare con siri con alexa con google
home riconoscono al volto ricostruiscono
in 3d in street view in google map tutte
le nostre case e le nostre
attività riconoscono i nostre impronte
digitali o analizzano i nostri testi
tutto questo fa parte della grande
categoria dell'intelligenza artificiale
così come fa parte della categoria dei
sistemi intelligenze artificiali le auto
che guidano da sole e che quindi
riescono a riconoscere il mondo esterno
per dare un input
alla guida ed allo sterzo e così come
purtroppo lo sono i droni che
ultimamente sappiamo in libia sono stati
utilizzati come armi di distruzione di
massa per riconoscere le persone ma non
sono gli aspetti negativi che mi
interessano perché in compenso pensiamo
a tutti i robot semplici e dotate
intelligenza artificiale che vengono
invece utilizzati per i bambini
autistici per poter imparare con loro e
assieme a loro come interfacciarsi con
con le persone sono sistemi di
intelligenza artificiale tutti i sistemi
di fan tech di di analisi dei dati negli
ambienti di produzione di ottimizzazione
della produzione
pensate per esempio a tutto il mondo del
predittiva analytics che riguarda la
possibilità di analizzare dati di
produzione e che tutti le analisi di
mercato ci dicono che nei prossimi
cinque anni avrà un incremento fino al
21 22 per cento
dal punto di vista dell'incremento delle
vendite della costruzione tutte questi
esempi sono esempi classici
all'intelligenza artificiale ma forse lì
ad esempio più importanti in
quest'ultimo periodo è l'esempio
dell'utilizzo dell'intelligenza
artificiale nell'ambito della medicina
per riconoscere nelle radiografie
se c'è la presenza di corrido altre di
malattia ma per riconoscere in tutti i
dati quello che sta succedendo e non
solo dati immagini ma anche nei dati di
genoma e
di tutte le altre informazioni che
derivano nel mondo della salute questo è
vero
quindi lei ai nasce per analizzare dati
comprenderli
prevedere anche quello che sta
succedendo ma anche di immaginare perché
c'è tutto un mondo che si chiama di
generativo design dove lei ha in viene
utilizzato per esempio per progettare
nuovi dispositivi per progettare nuovi
farmaci o anche per presentare come
stiamo facendo noi per esempio nuove
piastrelle o nuovi vestiti beh sono
virati una piccola interpretazione di
che cosa può essere intelligente
artificiale attorno a noi
e d'altra parte se vedete questo robot
che sta girando questo lo potete
considerare anche soltanto un mezzo di
locomozione un oggetto meccanico che
però si è dotato al proprio interno di
un piccolo e calcolatore come quello che
a testa un po di telecamere di sensori
può essere effettivamente come la
rappresentazione dell'intelligenza
artificiale secondo la comunità europea
ci dice un insieme di sistemi che vede
nel mondo acquisisce nel mondo ha un
comportamento intelligente intraprendere
azioni
naturalmente per per applicazioni
specifiche ecco ho utilizzato questi
minuti
iniziali per darvi un overview di quello
che tutti noi consideriamo ormai negli
anni dal punto di vista tecnologico e
vorrei utilizzare prossimi minuti invece
per pensare a che cosa è adesso della
ricerca che cosa potrà essere nel
prossimo futuro ora lei l'x è
considerata uno dei più grandi mezzi dal
punto di vista del software e dei
modelli matematici per generalizzare
dall'enorme quantità di dati riceve
l'ingresso grandissime quantità di dati
li elabora e ottimizza i propri
parametri interni che sono generali
dentro a delle reti che si chiamano reti
neurali artificiali e che riesce in base
a questo poi a dare delle uscite degli
output che sono simili a quelli che
potrebbero essere un comportamento
intelligente vi faccio due esempi
concreti per essere più chiaro un
esempio importante quello che si sta
facendo per la previsione del cancro al
seno cinque anni non solo di
riconoscerli una mammografia se c'era un
cancro al seno ma potere capire se
questo evolverà in cinque anni qualcosa
di male di benigno nel 2019 le mani ti
hanno fatto un sistema artificiale che
imparando da decine di migliaia di
immagini di mammografia è riuscito ad
avere una previsione corretta del 30 32
per cento rispetto al 18 20 per cento di
un essere umano di 1 grado di un medico
che è capace di fare questo non è ancora
tanto però risultati di un mese fa sono
stati quelli di mettere che mettendo
assieme i dati americani alle mighty
quelli svedesi e quei taiwan si è
arrivato ad una accuratezza fino al 45
per cento cosa ci dice questo ci dice
che se acquisiamo tantissime grandi
quantità di dati sicuramente il sistema
in grado di generalizzare di andare
sempre verso una precisione maggiore vi
faccio un secondo esempio che mi piace
molto perché lo stiamo sviluppando dei
nostri laboratori di unimore il sistema
adesso sono in grado non solo di capire
il parlato ma anche di generale del
testo ad esempio generale il testo
vedendo le immagini come in queste
immagini dove da una foto come questo un
sistema capace di dire che c'è una tazza
con delle fragole tagliate dei mandarini
pelati quindi qualcosa di estremamente
concreto e come fa un sistema realizzare
questo è imparato da tutte le pagine di
wikipedia ha imparato a tutti i dati sul
web quindi la capacità davvero di
generalizzare su grandissime quantità di
dati
bene io concludo però questo discorso
per dire che questa è la ricerca di oggi
è la produzione di oggi della iai delle
grandi costruttori casi costruttrici ma
se io vedo spero quello che dovrà essere
lei ai domani soprattutto in italia in
europa io vedo invece nei ai che dovrà
essere assolutamente iperpersonalizzata
che dovrà essere individuale che dovrà
essere unica cosa intendo per questo io
vorrei che in un futuro a un robot
mobile come questo che lavori con una
persona anziana posso inter interagire
con questa e se dice un freddo vada
direttamente a prendere la coperta
preferita senza dovere generalizzare su
tutto quello che gli utenti possono
avere in generale quando c'è freddo e
che devono essere personalizzati sulla
sull'esigenza sull'etica sul modo di
pensare dei singoli utenti non solo nel
mondo sociale ma anche nel mondo
lavorativo
pensate che nel mondo lavorativo
ho bisogno di sistema intelligenza
artificiale capace di conoscere il know
how di aziendale senza dovere per questo
condividerlo con quello di tutti gli
altri senza doverlo rendere
generalizzato a livello federato a
livello magari anche di altre aziende di
aziende straniere o di aziende
competitor ma che dovrà rimanere il know
how all'interno di chi lo ha creato così
come nella cappella sistina un
michelangelo capace di realizzare
meravigliosi esseri umani tutti diversi
dovremmo essere in grado di realizzare
meravigliosi sistemi artificiali tutte
diverse tutte specifiche per
l'applicazione quello che vi ho detto è
logico ma non è affatto concreto e un
enfant facile dal punto di vista di un
calcolatore e abbiamo dal punto di vista
la ricerca tantissime cose da fare
questa è una lista di nomi che di
tecniche che dovremmo imparare ad usare
tutti insieme quelli che gli inglesi si
chiamano schuchat learning imparare da
pochissimi esempi continua learning per
imparare in modo continuo plastic learn
in modo adattabile e modificabile come
fanno i nostri euroni le reti neurali
dovranno avere perfino la capacità di
dimenticare o di adattarsi in base
secondi concessi e dis per
specializzarsi in modo compatibile con
la privacy con il copyright e con tutti
i nostri valori
capite bene che c'è tanto da lavorare ma
non sono abbastanza convinta che che
questo ci riusciremo ci riusciremo anche
in italia e soprattutto ci riusciremo
qua in emilia romagna
ricordiamoci che qui in emilia romagna
siamo all'interno di un ecosistema la
nostra digital valley dove abbiamo i
supercalcolatori più importanti d'europa
abbiamo un un materiale umano un
patrimonio umano di grandi giovani
capaci e che stanno studiando a queste
tecnologie e quindi io sono
assolutamente sicura che l'ingegnere
domani riusciranno a realizzare i
sistemi di hi hi e risollevarsi anche da
questa pandemia come ha fatto mirandola
nel terremoto che è un esempio
assolutamente per tutta in un e ai
perdute in rayyan che per la medicina e
per la nostra vita
[Musica]